hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the first day of the opera euro
rapid finals it's wesley saw versus
magnus carlsen and in the second game
we've seen uh how uh
wesley uh prepared a perfect line but
then at the exact same moment when he
was supposed to gain uh the initiative
uh
he blundered he played a move that's not
one of uh
well what he prepared and then magnus
gained the upper hand and
was able to win game two game three
again a very slow one
not really anything to look forward
there and now
this game for wesley must win in order
uh not
to not to lose on on day one uh so
without further ado let's check it out
and let's see if they repeat
what was played in game two uh where
wesley
also had the white pieces so wesley
opens again with e4
and magnus again replies with e5 we have
knight f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 so for
those of you are wondering
yes i've checked if the camera and the
microphone were in place this time
so bishop to c4 and now magnus doesn't
go for knight to f6 like in the
uh previous video that we've shown but
now switches the bishop to c5 he's
asking are you maybe interested in going
for some evan's gambit action
and also i know you checked what went
wrong in the first game so i'm not
you know playing playing what i played
in the previous game again uh and wesley
not
interested in b4 this time goes for c3
and i've listened to a little bit of an
interview with wesley so after the game
it seems he did adjustable course on on
the
djoko piano on the main line this c3
idea here
and if any of you have checked this if
any of you have went through it
do also comment on it uh so i i know
what's happening in there so here we
have knight to f6
and now d4 uh striking in the center
we have e captures on d4 and now e5 so
this has all been
played before for like 150 years
we have d5 by black now challenging the
bishop and bishop to b5 so this is all
very standard stuff
knight to e4 getting the knight out of
harm's way and
c captures on d4 attacking the bishop
bishop back to b6 and now
knight to c3 putting pressure on this
knight we have castles
and bishop to e3 now wesley continues
development we have bishop to g4
attacking this knight and now h3 we have
bishop back to h5
and now comes queen to c2 usually you
don't want to allow this captures here
now to mess up your pawn structure but
here if black goes for this
uh it's not really uh doing anything for
black this knight can now be easily
kicked away from here and then you also
get the nice semi-open g file to use for
attack
so here instead after queen to c2 we
have bishop back to g6 by magnus
now putting the uh bishop in front of
the white queen here
and queen back to b3 now with a double
attack on the d5 pawn so like the e7
defending the d5 pawn
and also preparing c6 to kick away
white's light square bishop
so castles here and now c6 with bishop
back to d3
and now uh now the the most played move
interestingly in this position is knight
to d2
as this is all still very standard stuff
attacking the white queen
so after you capture this knight then
black captures the bishop here
but uh it's although very possible uh
it's not
uh what magnus wanted to play here so
instead after bishop to d3 magnus goes
knights to f5
and now he's keeping his options open
but uh you know you you can capture a
lot of stuff here
wesley goes back queen to c2 he adds the
defender here so the bishop is now
nicely defended
and there are a few games here most
notable one
uh from the european team championship
between eleven arunan and uh michael
adams from 2019 batumi
uh olympiad sorry not olympia european
team championship uh where
uh knight captures on e3 was played but
here we have knight characters on c3 and
it is as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game so let's see
how wesley continues we have b captures
on c3 knight captures on e3
f captures now doubling up his e pawn
but it is a very strong center and for
the moment it's locking uh
carlsen's dark square bishop out of the
game so bishop captures on d3
queen captures and now magnus strikes in
the center with f6 you should always be
careful when you're playing f6
but here it is uh justify justified as
it will uh will uh reduce
white's a majority in the center so c4
wesley gets rid of his backwards pawn
here and advances it now wants to trade
it here
we have bishop back to c7 now adding
another attacker here and also the
bishop will be very useful on this
diagonal
so c captures on the e5 and now not if
captures an e5 which is uh
probably uh how you want to play this
magnus goes queen captures on d5
and now wesley just goes uh e captures
on f6 and now magnus has to decide
uh the problem with capturing with the
rook is that you give
a white mini tempe for example e4
attacks the queen after the queen moves
e5 comes attacks the rook
and then who knows uh what's happening
here once the rook moves then you can go
like a knight g5 you can threaten
checkmate
you can threaten checkmate you can go
queen to b3 check
put some pressure on the king attack the
b7 pawn so a lot of a lot of
possibilities here
so magnus doesn't like this as i'm sure
he maybe
uh didn't have all this uh all this all
that well prepared uh
like wesley did so instead he played g
captures on f6 now
you will not be playing e5 and already
you are guarding both of these squares
on id5 or knight g5 are not possible
however e4 is played here queen to d7
and now rook 8 and d1 so now wesley has
a very strong center here
but uh carlsen's uh uh you know uh f and
c
pawn are doing a fine job of preventing
those pawns from
from moving forward so here rook eight
to d8 and now comes
knight to h4 without the presence of uh
carlson's light square bishop
the f5 square is free for grabs and now
this knight is coming to f5 and from
there
we'll see what happens so king the h8
magnus wants to free up the
g file for his rook to be used for
attacking purposes here
knight to f5 and now magnus decides to
strike in the center
with c5 so here uh he will either
capture on d4 or he will
allow wesley to advance the pawn to d5
but now the e5 square has been vacated
for the bishop so bishop to e5
and next he's preparing bishop to d4
check which will
uh remove the the queen and brooks
influence along the d
file all together so here we have rook
to b1
putting the rook on the semi open b file
and
now b6 not allowing the b71 to remain a
target
and now queen to c4 and this is uh this
move here is exactly what i believe that
wesley has this all
extremely well uh you know he's being
extremely well prepared
because queen to c4 is not a move that
comes to mind if you just you know
try and go for the attack or maybe
you're just trying to push for something
it's not all that easy you can't make
any rook lifts you can't go rook f4 here
because the bishop covers that you can't
go here and here because the bishop
covers the
the g3 square so the very silent queen
to c4
is actually extremely strong for two
reasons one it
after queen to c4 you can maybe make a
nice rook lift with rook to b3 to shift
the rook
to all the way to the king side but also
it prevents queen to a4 because if you
ask black here
excuse me uh good sir what what is your
next move if i just give you a move
black will probably say i'm gonna i'm
gonna play queen to a4 go after this
pawn here put pressure on
on the e4 pawn and the my queen will be
much better placed
than it currently is on d7 so wesley
plays queen c4
stops this uh and also the queen and
rook now nicely guarded the b5 square so
you you don't have any
chances of pushing any pawns here so
rook to f8 magnus now probably wants to
switch
his attention to the pawn here and also
if the bishop moves you might be able to
make a target of this pawn
so king to h1 not allowing any bishop to
d4 moves to come with
check uh bishop to d4 and now comes
rook to f4 by wesley uh if you go for
this knight captures on d4 idea
uh and it seems reasonable why not win a
pawn here then
rook captures an e4 and now the knight
cannot move you're gonna just grab that
knight
and if rook beat the d1 defending you
can just capture here and after captures
there's rook to e3
so white would be up a pawn but it would
be an extremely dangerous position to
play
uh as there are a lot a lot of tricks in
the position for example if you're not
careful play d6
all of a sudden rook the c8 the queen is
under attack and after remove the queen
rook captures on h3
and you know good good things can happen
for black you cannot capture because of
just check and also rook is coming to g8
and if you play king to g1
uh then rook to g3 and it's uh not an
easy position to play
queen is coming to h3 this other rook is
coming to g8 and it's going to be very
hard for white to defend
so instead after bishop to d4 we have
rooked the f4 by wesley by removing the
bishop here
uh magnus allowed wesley to do this very
nice rook lift
and now uh the pawn is also defended so
what is your plan here how are you
defending against the
bishop against knight captures bishop
well uh one thing that comes to mind is
just move the bishop back so
like bishop to e5 and now you attack the
rook so
what will whitey do here probably move
the rook back and then
wesley wesley needs to find some
different way of approaching this
position
uh but magnus did not go for that magnus
actually went for the kill he played uh
here after luke 24 he played rook
captures on e4
so he grabs a pawn and he uh allows
wesley to capture his rook but he's
gonna capture the knight here
and hopefully the d5 pawn so if he can
grab the two central pawns it's you know
giving up the exchange isn't such a bad
thing
so here wesley captures on e4 and now
queen
captures on f5 but now wesley goes to
rook beat the e1
threatening some uh rook to e8 check
ideas so magnus goes
rook captures on d5 but this is not
possible you once again
have to blockade with bishop to e5 to
continue playing this game
but magnus said nope we can do this he
played rook captures on d5 but now the
position is actually completely lost for
him as wesley finds a very quick way
to reach the black king he just plays
rook to g4
and now the king is completely cut off
uh the thread of rook the e8 will be
checkmate if black does nothing
so here magnus goes h5 makes some uh
room on h7 for his king rook the e8
would
check king to h7 and now rook to e7 with
check with king the h6 uh sorry not
not the king to h6 but it doesn't really
matter if you go king to h6
uh the same idea wins as if you go king
to h8 so king daychey was played
and i'll find this same idea it's abs
it's the exact same
wherever the king goes so feel free to
pause the video here and
win this game for wesley while i give
you a couple of seconds it's actually uh
it's actually a forced checkmate so you
know have at it
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
quickest way
to reach the black king and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to c1 uh this was played and it
was in this position on move 37 that
magnus carlsen resigned to the game
and uh with it the the victory in the
second match
so wesley successfully retaliated so
tomorrow we will see
whether the game whether the match will
be decided in the rapid section or will
we again go into blitz tie breaks and
then maybe maybe even armageddon
uh so um here we resign because there is
no defense against queen to h6
there is no move black can do to prevent
queen to h6 you could start giving up
material with moves like queen g5 but
that's just pointless i mean you you
give up the queen
and other than silly moves like that
there's simply no good move here
uh so yeah really really impressive
stuff so that's why i'm wondering
uh as wesley said that he did a lot of
work on his uh
course for the chestable uh so if any of
you have went through this and
if you if you uh you know have any uh
reviews of it to do
do share in the comment section i would
very much be interested in in hearing
your opinion
uh so uh an excellent comeback by wesley
so
not uh you know not allowing magnus to
just grab
grab a full point in the first day so
tomorrow it's gonna be pretty crazy as
tomorrow is the last day
and tomorrow everything will be settled
uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh as you can see uh the italian is
always always uh very very impressive
uh whether you go for you know the the
knight attack or the knight f6 or the
bishop to c5
you know there are so many so many of
these old lines that are now
uh you know revitalized and given new
life you know
via via our good friends the engines uh
so yeah uh that's it uh i would like to
thank then robert samuel moon
constantinos
romates minas joshi and the dragon spice
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals of
the final day checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day